ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
POWER QUE HAN BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
WROTE BURKE CALDERON CARILLO
CERVANTES CHAU JUNE DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DEEP.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY. MEDINA MULLIN SUSHI
THIS AREA OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SMITH STONE. TING VOEPEL
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. YEAH A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER. THIS MY
PRIVILEGES HONOR TO BE HERE
TODAY TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
OPENING PRAYER. TODAY
SYMBOLIZES THE ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY. THAT THE GOVERNOR
DID A FORMAL APOLOGY FOR
GENOCIDE AN ATROCITY AGAINST A
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. IN LIGHT OF
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
WE STAND UNITED AS A BODY. IN
WITH OUR LEADERS MOVING FORWARD
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO IN THIS PRAYER
THAT I'LL BE OFFERING. IT TALKS
ABOUT. THE WORLD HOW IT WAS
DARK IN THE PEOPLE CAME TO BE.
IN OUR CLAN THE HOBBY IT THEN
PLAN OF THE SERRANO PEOPLE.
SUFFERED UNDER. THE DIRECTION
OF THIS FIRST GOVERNOR TO PUT
OUT BOUNTIES ON CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE. AND FUNDED MILITIAS. TO
RID. THE RACE OF THE INDIAN
PEOPLE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TODAY THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THE MAKE UP OF
IT IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT. THAN
WHAT IT WAS BACK THEN AND I
OFFER THIS SONG UP IN PRAYER.
STE. NO PROMO ARE ONLY JONES
GOOD JOHN GOOD G. ALL NOT ALL
OMAHA JONES GOOD I'M GOING TO
FOLLOW PHONE MODEL JOHN GOOD
TIMES GOOD TO FOLLOW I PHONE
NOT ON A JOHN GOOD TO TIMES
GOOD HOME JONES GO USED PHONE I
A JOHN. PHONE NOT AYE AYE JONES
GOOD J. TOM START HOME OP PHONE
NOT ON A JOHN BUDGET R. TOM'S
GOOD HOME UP HOME OUT ON A JOB
GOOD K. TOM ALL OUT YOUR A
BOMBS PHONE NOT OUT YOUR. HOME
OMAN ON YOUR- LONG VEHICLE OWN
NOT A HOME OUT ON YOUR. YOUR
HOBBY AT SOME PHONE MARROW
YOU'LL HAVE YOU TOM ALL MY OWN
MIND I YOUR. I'LL BE AT TIMES
PHONE MODEL MONO HOBBY IT'S ON.
I DO HOBBY OF SOULS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER AHMANN. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AT THE JOINT IS
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MEMBERS
JOIN ME IN A SALUTE TO OUR
NATION'S FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. TO. AND WHY NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE YEAH.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED
LIVING THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO MONDAY MARCH
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY THE
CEMENT AT ONE PM THEY ARE WELL.
AS WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE. DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NINE INTRODUCTION THE
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS IN COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR MOTION THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STONE FONG ANDY GARCIA TO SPEAK
ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY
THAT INJECTIONS ACTUALLY THE
ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE I'M
GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE ITEM A FOURTEEN SB ONE
THREE TWO WIENER FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE. WHEN THEY'RE
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SEVEN I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE I'M EIGHTEEN
SB ONE FOURTEEN SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ITEM NINETEEN SB
NINETY SEVEN SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW AND
OBJECTION SUCH THE ORDER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS TO YOUR BILL
SIXTY TWO A THE FILE NOTICE.
BUDGET COMMITTEE. WHOLE SKEWS
ME BUDGET SUB NUMBERS TO HOLD.
A HEARING NEXT WEEK CALL OF THE
CHAIR. MR FOR. AND MR FLORA
THANK YOU SPEAKER WITH HOLDING
OUT CONCERT WORLD VOTE. MR CALL
MOVES IN MISTER VICE SEC AND
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE MR IS AFTER FR
A FIVE MISTER IS A FOR AN VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A- ALL.
MEMBERS VOTED AS IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED A. CLERK WILL-CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THOSE
GUYS FORTY EIGHT KNOWS TWELVE.
THE MOTION PASSES. MOTION
CARRIES MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT REAL
SIXTY TWO A THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE TO HEAR SB FOUR
TWENTY THREE NEXT WEEK PLAN
CALLED CHAIR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADOPTING AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
FOR WE HOLDING ASPEN SAID NOW
ROLL CALL. HERE MISTER CALLED
MOVES BONTA SECOND. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS A SEE DROVE
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING AN
AYE VOTE MISTER FLORES ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE ALL MEMBERS GO TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY VOTE
ICE FIFTY ONE NEWS TWELVE THE
MOTION CARRIES. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTY THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
MIDDLE AGED SIXTY BY SOME
REMEMBER BERMAN OTHERS MACLAINE
TO ELECTION TO THE CLEAR
THERE'S OF TECH FAQ MEDIALLY
MISTER BERMAN YOU RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES. NO ONE SHOULD HAVE
TO RISK THEIR HEALTH AND
POSSIBLY THEIR LIFE TO EXERCISE
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
VOTE. YEAH THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE SAW ON APRIL SEVENTH SEVENTH
OF THIS YEAR WHEN WISCONSINITES
WERE FORCED TO VOTE IN PERSON
IN THE PRIMARY ELECTION
STANDING FOR HOURS IN LINES
THAT STRETCH FOR MILES. DESPITE
THE BEST EFFORTS OF ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS THOUSANDS OF VOTERS
WHO REQUESTED ABSENTEE BALLOTS
DID NOT RECEIVE THEM IN TIME TO
VOTE IN RETURN THE BY ELECTION
DAY. THEY WERE EFFECTIVELY
DISENFRANCHISED. THIS IS WHY
I'VE INTRODUCED AB EIGHT SIXTY
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THAT EVERY
ACTIVE REGISTERED CALIFORNIA
VOTER EMAIL THE BALLOT FOR THIS
NOVEMBER'S GENERAL ELECTION.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA VOTER HAS THE OPTION
TO VOTE FROM THE SAFETY OF
THEIR OWN HOME. AB EIGHT SIXTY
MAKES A NUMBER OF OTHER
IMPORTANT ACCOMMODATIONS TO
HELP FACILITATE THE EXPECTED
SURGE IN VOTING. BY MAIL AT
THIS NOVEMBER'S ELECTION. IT
ALLOWS COUNTIES TO BEGIN
PROCESSING RETURN VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS EARLIER SO THAT THEY
CAN BETTER MANAGE THEIR
WORKLOAD TO GET MORE BALLOTS
COUNTED ON ELECTION NIGHT. AND
IT EXTENDS THE DEADLINE FOR
SEAT VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS SO
THAT VOTERS ARE NOT
DISENFRANCHISED BY POTENTIAL
POSTAL SERVICE DELAYS. IT
ALLOWS ALL VOTERS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE FLEXIBILITY
OFFERED BY MY REMOTE ACCESSIBLE
VOTE BY MAIL SYSTEMS WHICH CAN
BE ESPECIALLY HELPFUL FOR
VOTERS WHO NEED REPLACEMENT
BALLOTS. OR WHO WANT TO RECEIVE
A BALLOT IN THEIR PREFERREDLANGUAGE. FINALLY AB IT SIXTEEN
STORES THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
VOTERS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TRACK THEIR BALLOTS AS THEY
MOVE THROUGH THE MAIL SYSTEM
AND ARE PROCESSED BY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS. AB EIGHT SIXTY IS
SUPPORTED BY MORE THAN TWO
DOZEN CALIFORNIA ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE. THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS.
AS WELL AS MY SECRETARY OF
STATE ALEX PADILLA. IT HAD
BOUGHT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
THE SENATE FLOOR AND WAS
APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY IN THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE EARLIER
THIS WEEK. THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN
MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MANISTIQUE
REMEMBERS I RISE TO. GIVE A
SIGNIFICANT RECOGNITION TO THE
AUTHOR AS WELL AS THE CHAIR OF
THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE AS WE
ALL KNOW THE AUTHOR HAS
INTRODUCED THE INTRODUCED THIS
BILL AND THIS LEGISLATION BACK
IN APRIL TWO WHICH THEN THE
MINISTRATION SUBSEQUENTLY IN.
IT'S TO THE- POINTS ARE THIS
RECEIPT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE WHICH
GOES TO SHOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
INCREASING DEMOCRACY AND ACTION
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE MISTER
KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR CHAMBER. THE SPEAKER I
RISE IN SUPPORT EVEN THOUGH I
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS THAT
I REMAIN TO BE ADDRESSED WITH
THE BILL I INCLUDING WHETHER
THE RIGHT SAFEGUARDS ARE IN
PLACE OF HOW WORKABLE IS FOR
OUR COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICES
BUT I APPRECIATE THE
WILLINGNESS. OF THE AUTHOR TO
HAVE A DIALOGUE ON THIS AND THE
WORK OF THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
NO LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS
PERFECT IN OUR PARTICULAR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS
ESPECIALLY IN PERECT BUT IT
SURE BEATS NO PROCESS AND SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THIS
BILL- MAKE IT TO THE DESK OF
THE GOVERNOR. TO ASSURE THAT
OUR ELECTION IN NOVEMBER IS
CONDUCTED IN A WAY THAT IS
SAFE. IN A WAY THAT PROVIDES
THE FULLEST MEASURE OF ACCESS
TO EVERY CALIFORNIA VOTER AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY IN A WAY
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM OF
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU MISTER
KILEY MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
SIXTY. AS WE JUST HAD THIS BILL
IN OUR COMMITTEE IN THE
ELECTIONS A REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE EARLIER THIS WEEK- I
WANT TO FIRST COMMEND THE
AUTHOR WHO YOU KNOW HAS WHO
STARTED HIS BACK IN APRIL- YOU
KNOW WORKING ON THIS PIECE OF A
LESS. OF LEGISLATION OBVIOUSLY
RECOGNIZING THE GREAT
IMPORTANCE OF WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH KOBE NINETEEN AND THINKING
ABOUT OUR ELECTIONS PROCESS.
TAKING TAKING INPUT. I HAVE I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ROCK AND IT'S NOT A PERFECT
BILL THERE'S THINGS IN HERE I
AM. THAT I DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT- BUT I ONE OF THINGS I
WANT TO NOTICES THE AUTHOR.
TOOK AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT NO IN ACTIVE- NO
INACTIVE VOTER WOULD RECEIVE A
MAIL BALLOT WHICH I THINK IS AN
IMPORTANT PROTECTION. HAD IT
IS. IT IS PART OF CURRENT LAW
BUT THAT NEEDS TO BE THAT
NEEDED TO BE CLARIFIED. ANOTHER
THING THAT'S IN HERE THAT THE
ACTUALLY WASN'T IN THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER BUT
I THINK IS IMPORTANT IS. IS
THAT IT ALLOWS FOR COUNTIES TO
USE THEIR OWN TRACKING SYSTEM.
THAT THEY ARE NOT FORCED TO USE
ONLY THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
TRACKING SYSTEM. NOW THAT'S
COMES FROM INPUT. THAT WE
RECEIVED. FROM COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS AND GOES TO ANOTHER
POINT OF WHY IT'S IMPORTANT AT
THE LEGISLATURE. DOES THIS
WORK. WHY IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
THESE THINGS ARE NOT DONE BY AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER CHANGING
ELECTIONS CODES AND STATUTES-
UNILATERALLY BUT RATHER THE
LEGISLATURE IS THE ONE THAT
NEEDS TO DO THIS WORK. AND I
THINK THIS PROCESS THE SHOW NOT
ONLY THAT- WELL IT IS THE DUTY
FREE FIRST AND FOREMOST AND IT
IS OUR LEGISLATIVE POWERS-
CONSIST WITH OUR LEGISLATIVE
POWERS TO DO THIS- BUT IT SHOWS
THAT WE CAN ACT. QUICKLY OUT
THIS IS BEING PASSED ON URGENCY
BECAUSE AND WE ARE BEING ABLE
TO DO THIS AND GIVE DIRECTION
TO OUR ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. ON
HOW WE CAN CONDUCT. AN ELECTION
SAFELY- BUT ALSO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY. OF THAT ELECTION A
LONG TERM ONE MORE THING I WANT
TO POINT OUT IS THAT IS.
ANOTHER THING THIS BILL DOES IS
ENSURE THAT. BALLOTS THAT ARE
COMING IN AFTER THE ELECTION DO
GO THROUGH A VETTING PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY WERE. IN FACT
CAST. HONOR BEFORE ELECTION DAY
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PROTECTION.
OTHERS PUT INTO THIS BILL. AND
SO WITH ALL THESE THINGS AGAIN
IT SHOWS THAT. YES INDEED THE
LEGISLATURE DOES WORK- AND THAT
WE CAN. AND TODAY WILL- ACT. TO
ENSURE SAFE AND FAIR ELECTIONS
AND WE DO NOT NEED THE
EXECUTIVE. TO A SERVE OUR
AUTHORITY AND PASS- EXECUTIVE
ORDERS IN ADVANCE OF US THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER LARGER AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER BERMAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. MADAM
SPEAKER IN JUST WILL APPRECIATE
THE CALM IN THE THIS THAT I'VE
RECEIVED FROM MANY COLLEAGUES
INCLUDING OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
pNICHOLAS AND ROCK WINNING
CAMPBELL- AND YOU KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO TRY TO
IDENTIFY ANY OF THE POTENTIAL-
ISSUES THAT OUR ELECTION SYSTEM
MY FACE IN NOVEMBER AND GET
AHEAD OF IT AND MAKE SURE THAT
OUR- ELECTIONS CLERKS. I HAVE
THE TIME. TAKEN DR URBAN.
IMPORTANT ELECTION DURING IT
REMARKABLY UNIQUE TIMES- SO
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR THIS.
BILL AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BERMAN THE CLERK WILLOPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS GO THERE TO
THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESERVE A- ON MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY A.
OKAY YEAH. WHERE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE TALLIED VOTES AYES SIXTY
THREE NO TO ANY URGENCY I
SIXTEEN THREE NO TO SEND
AMENDMENTS COMPARED IN.
MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE THIRTY
TWO SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
IMPLEMENT MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OR FOR. MR COLOR
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN
WHICH PROVIDES NECESSARY LEAVE
AND JOB PROTECTION TO PROMOTE
HEALTHY WORKPLACES AND TO
PROTECT THE ECONOMIC WELL BEING
OF CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES IN THIS GLOBAL
HEALTH CRISIS AND IN FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES. OVER
THE PAST THREE MONTHS THE STATE
IS DEVOTED HIMSELF TO HELPING
BEND THE CURVE AND REDUCE THE
IMPACT OF THIS VOTE THAT THAT
THIS VIRUS IS HAVING ON OUR
COMMUNITIES. CALIFORNIA IT'S
COUNTIES AND CITIES A LOCAL
COMMUNITIES OF MAKE GREAT
SACRIFICES TO PROVIDE FOR THE
OVERALL PUBLIC HEALTH. WHAT
THIS VIRUS HAS DEMONSTRATED IS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S LEAVE AND
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS ARE
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE TO ADDRESS
AND RESPOND TO THIS AND OTHER
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES. THIS
BILL IS A REFLECTION OF THE
REAL TIME NEEDS IMPOSED BY
COVER NINETEEN. IT EXPANDS
ACCESS TO UNPAID JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE HELPING TO ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYEES CAN STAY HOME IF THEY
OR A LOVED ONE HAS BEEN
IMPACTED BY COVERT NINETEEN I'M
NOT PLACE OTHERS AT GREATER
RISK OF TRANSMISSION. THAT ALSO
MINIMALLY EXPANDS NEEDED PAID
SICK LEAVE AND LIMITS ACCESS TO
A PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WHICH
IS CRITICAL FOR WORKERS TO MEET
THE TWO WEEK MANDATORY
QUARANTINE PERIOD TO FURTHER
PROTECT THEMSELVES THEIR
COWORKERS AND THE GREATER
PUBLIC HEALTH. IT WOULD ALSO
HELP ENSURE THE ECONOMY IS
READY TO RE OPEN OF THE LIFE
BLOOD OF OUR STATE'S ECONOMY
IT'S WORKERS CAN GET BACK TO
WORK QUICKLY AND SAFELY TO THE
STATUS OF A RITE OF RETENTION.
KALRA NINETEEN IS MAGNIFIED THE
INEQUITIES ABOUT LEAVE LAWS
WHICH HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY
THE RECENTLY ADOPTED. FEDERAL
FAMILIES FIRST CORONAVIRUS ACT
EXCLUDING OVER TWELVE MILLION
WORKERS FROM ACCESSING THE
FEDERAL PAID SICK LEAVE
PROGRAM. AS A RESULT FAR TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS.
DISPROPORTIONATELY PEOPLE OF
COLOR IMMIGRANTS AND WOMEN.
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL SERVICES
DURING THIS TIME. ARE FACING
THE IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE BETWEEN
WORKING WHILE SICK OR LOSING
THE INCOME THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
BE THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. IN THE PAST THREE
MONTHS INDUSTRIES SUCH AS
HOTELS AIRPORT HOSPITALITY
ADVANCERS CENTERS AND BUILDING
SERVICES HAVE LAID OFF ONE
THIRD OR MORE OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES. WORKERS IN THESE
INDUSTRIES ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND IMMIGRANTS
AND WOMEN. WHO ARE ALREADY
ECONOMICALLY AND PHYSICALLY
GETTING HIT HARDEST BY COVERT
NINETEEN AS THE DATA IS SHOWING
US ALL TOO CLEARLY. THESE
WORKERS OF LOST THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING COMPLETELY
OUT OF THEIR CONTROL NOT
BECAUSE OF POOR PERFORMANCE OR
DISCIPLINE BECAUSE OF A CRISIS
NOT OF THEIR MAKING. THESE
WORKERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO GO
BACK TO THEIR JOBS WHEN THE
CRISIS HAS ENDED. AS IS
EVIDENCED BY THE NUMEROUS
AMENDMENTS TAKEN ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. I
WILL CONTINUE. TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO MAKE REASONABLE
AMENDMENTS AND IN FACT HAVE
HAVE COMMITTED AND WILL COMMIT
TO REDUCING THE NUMBER OF PAID
SICK LEAVE DAYS FROM SEVEN TO
THREE DAYS. ALSO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OPPOSITION OF
COLLEAGUES TO HAVE CONCERNS ON
ISSUES OF A RITE OF ATTENTION
AND RECALL I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERNS ARE LEGITIMATE I SHARE
THOSE SAME CONCERNS. AND I WILL
COMMIT TO. NOT JUST MAKE THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE PAID SICK
LEAVE. OF THE DAYS BUT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK. SO THAT WE
CAN FIND THE BALANCE OF I WILL
ALSO MAKE IT A MINUTE SORRY
THAT ALL EXAM BUSINESSES ARE
CLOSED DURING AN EMERGENCY- BUT
I ALSO WORK TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE UNDUE BURDENS ON
BUSINESS. BUT I WANT TO ALSO
ENSURE THAT THE PRINCIPLES ARE
PROTECT OUR WORK ALSO REMAIN IN
PLACE THE BALANCE IS DIFFICULT
TO FIND BUT I BELIEVE WE CAN
FIND IT REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
PAID SICK LEAVE. DAYS I BELIEVE
IS GOES A LONG WAY FINDING THAT
BALANCE. ULTIMATELY WE MUST
ALLOW EMPLOYEES IMPACTED BY
KOBE NINETY TO RECOVER AWAY
FROM WORK WITHOUT FEAR OF
RISKING THEIR EMPLOYMENT OR
PLACING THEIR COWORKERS ARREST.
THEY ARE DOING WHAT PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUIRES AND DEMANDS OF
THEM. LET'S NOT PUNISH THEM
FURTHER. WE MUST ALSO LOOK TO
THE FUTURE AND IMPLEMENT LONG
TERM POLICIES THAT WILL HELP
GET PEOPLE TO A CRISIS LIKE
THIS USER WE DON'T WANT TO
KEEP. THROUGH THIS TIME THERE'S
AN EMERGENCY FIGURING OUT HOW
TO STRIKE THIS PROPER BALANCE.
WE CANNOT WAIT AND WE MUST NOT
WAIT ON A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA MISS REST YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARISES
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF AB THREE
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN. THIS BILL
PROVIDES NECESSARY JOB
PROTECTIONS TO TWELVE MILLION
WORKERS LEFT OUT OF THE FEDERAL
SICK LEAVE PROGRAM. THIS
PANDEMIC IS HIGHLIGHTED THE
INEQUALITIES OF OUR ECONOMY AND
OUR EMPLOYMENT LAWS. YES WE'RE
STILL IN A PANDEMIC WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO PHYSICALLY DISTANCE
AND MINIMIZE CONTACT WITH
OTHERS. THIS PANDEMIC HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED LOW
INCOME WORKERS PHYSICALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY. AS OF YESTERDAY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH REPORTED ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE CASES OF
COVERT NINETEEN IN CALIFORNIA.
OF THAT NUMBER 600-003-0070
SEVEN REPORTED CASES. 56% OF
THE CALL WOULD NINETEEN CASES
IN CALIFORNIA AFFECTED MEMBERS
OF THE LATIN NEXT COMMUNITY.
LOW WAGE WORKERS MAKE UP. OVER
50% OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS. THESE
WORKERS PARTICULARLY PEOPLE OF
COLOR IMMIGRANTS AND WOMEN ARE
FACING THE IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE
BETWEEN WORKING WHILE SICK OR
LOSING THE INCOME THEY RELY ON
TO FEED THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND KEEP A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEAD. AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN WOULD ALLOW THESE
WORKERS TO STAY HOME WHEN THEY
ARE SICK. AND RECOVER WITHOUT
FEAR OF LOSING THEIR JOB. AB
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN PROTECTS
WORKERS THEIR FAMILIES THEIR
WORKPLACES THEIR EMPLOYERS.
EVEN THE CUSTOMERS FROM AN
INCREASED RISK OF SPREAD OF
COVERT NINETEEN. I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO ADD AMENDMENTS TO
TAKE CARE OF THOSE CONCERNS.
AND I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK
YOU MISS RAY S. DOCTOR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED NO. MISTER IS THERE
AND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
BETTER TRACTION. IS THERE A AND
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS UP
UNTIL LATE LAST NIGHT JUST ONE
OF VERIFY IS THERE A THRESHOLD
FOR THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES FOR
THE SMALL BUSINESS COMPONENT OF
THIS BILL. MISTER HOWARD LIKE
CANCER. AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS
A SUMMER ARE COLLEAGUE IS
REFERRING TO THE PAID SICK
LEAVE AND KNOW ABOUT GIVEN THE
FACT THAT SICK LEAVE RIGHT NOW
DOES NOT HAVE AN EXEMPTION
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S-
APPROPRIATE FOR US TO START
CREATING EXEMPTIONS FOR WHAT
SHOULD BE A RIGHT FOR ALL
WORKERS THAT'S WHY I'M MOVING
ON THE SEVENTY THREE DAYS TO
TRY TO FIND THE BALANCE OF THE
IMPACT TO TOP IT ALL THE
WORKERS OR ON THE BUSINESSES.
OKAY MISTER VERY ON YOUR TIME.
A THANK YOU I JUST WANTED
CLARIFY THAT AND I AS MUCH AS I
RESPECT THE WORK THAT MY
COLLEAGUE IS DOING FROM SAN
JOSE AND I VERY MUCH WOULD ONE
APPRECIATE THIS BILL THAT
PROVISION IS A STICKING POINT
FOR ME I DO NOT UNDERSTAND HOW
WE CAN KEEP. HOW WE CAN COMPARE
SMALL BUSINESSES OF FIVE OF
THREE EMPLOYEES TO LARGER SIZED
BUSINESSES WE NEED TO OPERATE
THAT WE PROTECT SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THE- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SEEING AND HEARING.
MR HER THIRTY IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER. ALSO WANTED TO
ECHO THE CONCERNS RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. YOU KNOW I THINK WE ALL
WANT TO SUPPORT OUR WORKERS
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS PANDEMIC
I THINK IT MAKES GOOD PUBLIC
HEALTH SENSE TO- INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO STAY HOME.
YOU KNOW DIRT DURING A
PANDEMIC- YOU KNOW I BUT BUT MY
CONCERN ARE THE MOM AND POP
SMALL BUSINESSES I TALKED TO
ONE OF MY FAVORITE RESTAURANTS
LAST NIGHT THE GUARDINO BOWLING
GARDENA NOW IF YOU'RE REALLY
ANY GREAT WINE FOOD- IN THE
THEY STOP BY THE GARDEN A BALL.
BUT YOU KNOW I TALKED TO ONE OF
THE OWNERS LAST NIGHT AND- AND
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT. HOW YOU
KNOW ME THERE THERE THERE'S A
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE DURING
THIS PANDEMIC IT'S NOT JUST THE
WORKERS THAT ARE STRUGGLING
IT'S- IT'S THESE MOM AND POP
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE.
REALLY STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE-
TO GET THROUGH THIS AND THEY
THEY CHOSE NOT TO CALL A SHUT
DOWN I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
MAKING THE- THE- EXCEPTION FOR
BIT OF BUSINESSES THAT CLOSE
DOWN DURING A- PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. BUT YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE THE THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE TRYING TO. STRUGGLE
WITH THAT TAKE OUTS- AND
THEY'RE BARELY MAKING IT. AND I
IT WHEN I WAS TALKING TO THE
AUTHOR LAST ENEMY HE HE KIND
OF- CONFIDED WITH ME THAT HE
HE'S ACTUALLY HE SAID YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M ACTUALLY A- A BERNIE
GUY HE'S HE'S A BERNIE CRACK.
AND HE WANTS TO DO NO HE HE
RECOGNIZES THAT THAT- THAT
WORKERS NEED TO BE TAKEN CARE
OF BUT THAT'S HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS FOR A LOT OF THE SMALL
BUSINESSES TO MAKE THINGS WORK
DURING THIS ENDEMIC- SO. YOU
KNOW I. IT IT'S A TOP OUT FOR
ME BUT- YOU KNOW BAD BECAUSE
THE AUTHORS MAYBE AMENDMENT TO
GO FROM SEVEN DAYS TO THREE SIX
DAYS- I'M I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL BUT I HOPE THAT YOU
KNOW WE DON'T JUST TALK ABOUT
VULNERABLE WORKERS WE TALK
ABOUT WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT THE
VULNERABLE SMALL BUSINESS THE
MOM AND POP SMALL BUSINESSES
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
MOORE THIRTY SIR FOR YOUR
RECORD STE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER OPPOSITION TO THIS IT
IS INTERESTING FIRST AND WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. BUT IF THIS IS A
COVERT. BILL THEN WHY ISN'T
THERE AN URGENCY CLAWS ON IT
THIS BILL IS NOT GOING TO GO
INTO EFFECT UNTIL JANUARY SO IF
WE'RE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
PROTECT PEOPLE THAT WERE LAID
OFF DURING THE COLD CRISIS.
SURE SEEMS LIKE IT SHOULD HAVE
AN EMERGENCY CLAUSE BUT MY FEAR
IS THAT'S NOT EXACTLY WHAT THIS
BILL IS THIS IS SOMETHING WE'VE
TRIED TO DO FOR AWHILE. IN MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID IT A
COUPLE TIMES I WANT TO
REITERATE THIS. MAIN STREET
AMERICA HAS BEEN DECIMATED.
THROUGH THIS COVERT CRISIS. AND
IF THERE IS NOT AN EXEMPTION
FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
WHETHER THE FLOWER SOP
WHATEVER THAT MAY BE AND
THERE'S ONLY ONE OR TWO
EMPLOYEES THERE. THOSE FOLKS
CANNOT SURVIVE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS I UNDERSTAND LARGE
BUSINESSES CERTAIN SIZE
BUSINESS CAN ACTUALLY DEAL WITH
THIS. BUT WHEN YOU START THINK
ABOUT MAIN STREET AMERICA. WHEN
THERE IS NO EXEMPTS. IS REALLY
REALLY PER ALEX I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN OVER THANK YOU
MISTER FLORA MISS GONZALES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I
RISE IN SUPPORT AND PROUD JOIN
AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE AND I
JUST WANT TO POINT SOMETHING
OUT TO PEOPLE ON THE FLOOR I
KNOW WE BUY INTO TALKING POINTS
A LOT AND START GETTING
WORRIED. THE TRUTH IS EVERY
WORKER DESPITE WHERE THEY WORK
DESERVES THE SAME PROTECTIONS.
IN REALITY THE SMALL BUSINESSES
WHETHER TO FLORES OR
RESTAURANT. IF THEY'RE
OPERATING THE CITIES OF LOS
ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO SAN DIEGO
AMERI BILL THERE ARE YOU
PROVIDING THIS MUCH SICK LEAVE
DANCE EXCEPT IT'S SUCCEEDING AT
THE SAME TIME. WHEN YOU OPERATE
A SMALL BUSINESS ESPECIALLY
RESTAURANT IN YOU HAVE A WORKER
WHO SICK DURING A PANDEMIC WITH
A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS DO YOU
REALLY WANT THEM TO COME INTO
YOUR SMALL BUSINESS. IN IN FACT
EVERYBODY ELSE ARE WE GOING TO
SAY THAT THEIR SPECIAL TIME.
WHEN WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
SOMEBODY CAN STAY HOME AND IT
BECOMES. EASY WE'RE GOING TO
WORK BECAUSE I GUARANTEE YOU
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO PREVENT
THAT WORKER WHEN IN. BECAUSE IF
IT'S BETWEEN PAYING THEIR BILLS
ARE STAYING HOME SICK THEY'RE
GOING TO PAY THEIR BILLS WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE. IT BUT
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN AS WE RE
OPEN A PANDEMIC THAT THAT
THRIVES ON. IT WILL BE IN A
SMALL WORKPLACE TOGETHER AN
ADDITIONAL THREE DAYS IS LIKE I
SAID NO MORE THAN SMALL
BUSINESSES ALREADY BEAR IN A
MAJORITY OF THE BIG CITIES. IN
CALIFORNIA AND YET DURING A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY I THINK
THEY CAN BEAR IN THE SMALL
CITIES TO. AND WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS IT IN
PARTICULAR IS THESE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS PRIMARILY MIGRANT
WORKERS WHO HAVE. BEEN FORCED.
TO GO TO. SEC RED. IT WORKPLACE.
THEY HAVE NO OTHER. I THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE BILL. I ALSO WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THE- ON THE-
IS WHAT NEED IN ORDER TO. THAT
THAT HOTELS AND OTHER THINGS
THAT WE HAVE GIVEN PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES TO IN AND HAVE
SUPPORTED SUPPORT THEIR VERY
WORKERS THAT WORKED THERE
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL. IT MAY NOT BE
PERFECT RIGHT NOW IT STILL HAS
TO GO THROUGH THE SENATE. I
JUST ASK THAT WE HAVE SOMETHING
THAT ACTUALLY PROTECTS WORKERS
DURING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER.
WELL MISTER. NOW OKAY YOU.
NEVER MIND MR BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I'M MATTER SPEAKER I
JUST WANT TO RAISE MY VOICE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS A PROUD
CO AUTHOR I DO APPRECIATE THAT
CONVERSATION- IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO TRY TO STRIKE THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN OUR OUR
BUSINESS COMMITTEE OR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WORKERS BUT THIS
IS THE TIME WE NEED TO STAND UP
FOR OUR WORKERS WE NEED WE'VE
CALLED OUR- OUR OUR FRONTLINE
WORKERS ESSENTIAL. WE CALL THEM
HEROES AND THEY ARE IN OUR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS NEED
ESSENTIAL PROTECTIONS THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO MAKE A CHOICE
ABOUT GOING TO WORK RISKING
THEIR OWN HEALTH RISK IN THE
HEALTH OF THEIR LOVED ONES
RISKY COMMUNITY HEALTH AND
PUTTING FOOD ON THEIR TABLE
THIS IS AN PROTECTION IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO THIS IS THE
TIME TO STAND UP WE HAVE A AN
AUTHOR. A LEAD AUTHOR WHO'S
WILLING TO WORK ON THESE ISSUES
GOING FORWARD SO YOU'RE RIGHT
THE FLAG THEN LET'S MOVE THIS
OFF THE FLOOR TODAY THE
PROVIDER ESSENTIAL WORKERS WITH
THE ESSENTIAL PROTECTIONS THAT
THEY DESERVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR BONTA MEMBERS IF YOU SEE
RECOGNITION PLEASE GO TO THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER RAISE YOUR
MAKES. MISTER KARGER YOU ARE
RIGHT. I WANT TO THANK YOU. I.
R. IN THE ROBUST. THAT WE HAD
ON THE- ON THIS. AND AT THE
THAT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HERE'S- A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
WORK. TO IT. SMALL BUSINESS.
CONTINUE TO BE THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. LOOKING
VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES. IT SOME PEOPLE HERE SAID
WHAT'S GONNA BREAK. A SMALL
BUSINESSES. SCHEDULING AROUND A
PERSON WHO TAKES THREE DAYS
OFF. IS NOT GOING TO BREAK A
SMALL BUSINESS. IT'S JUST
SIMPLY NOT. I DON'T SEE THAT IT
AND IT'S BEEN ECHOED AND IT'S
BEEN A GOOD BEFORE IF YOU'RE SO
IF SOMEBODY IS SICK YOU SAY YOU
DON'T WANT YOU CERTAINLY DON'T
WANT THEM AT WORK. THIS SIMPLE.
MINOR BILL THE GIVES SOMEBODY
ABILITY. TO STAY HOME FOR THREE
DAYS. AND CERTAINLY IF IT IF
THE BILL AT THE BILL CONTINUES
SOME OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
ISSUES COULD BE ADDRESSED. BUT
WE DON'T WANT TO STOP A BILL.
THAT IS GOING TO PROTECT FRONT
LIGHT WORKERS ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND THE VERY COMMUNITIES THAT
WE REPRESENT. THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT NOW THERE'S BEEN TALK
THAT TALK ABOUT RETENTION OF
WORKERS BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT
WHAT REALLY HAPPENS. IF YOU'RE
A LOW INCOME WORKERS IN SOME OF
THE SECTORS AND YOU JUST DON'T
WANT TO BRING THAT EMPLOYEE
BACK. YOU DON'T IF YOUR
EMPLOYER WHO'S TRYING TO TRIED
TRIED BUT- ORGANIZED IN THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS
YOU DON'T WANT TO TAKE THIS
EMPLOYEE BACK YOU DON'T AND YOU
CAN HIDE BEHIND A WHOLE HECK OF
A LOT OF RULES. IF YOU'RE AN
EMPLOYEE WHOSE MAKE A LITTLE
BIT MORE THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE.
AND YOU DON'T WANT TO TAKE THAT
EMPLOYEE BACK. YOU PROBABLY
WON'T. THIS IS MEANT TO GIVE
SOME SORT OF SOME SORT OF LEGAL
STANDING TO EMPLOY TO WORKERS.
WHO HAD TO LEAVE FOR NO OTHER
REASON THAT WAS A PANDEMIC THIS
YEAR THESE ARE WORKERS WHO WENT
HOME BECAUSE THEY FELT LIKE IT
ONE DAY. THESE ARE WORKERS
WHO'S JUST DECIDED TO SKIP WORK
PROTEST THE FACT THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO WORK GO HOME AND NOT
PAY THEIR BILLS. AND LET'S BE
REAL ABOUT THIS. WORK WE HAD TO
STAY HOME. BECAUSE IT WAS A PAN
MAKE. AND THEY GET SICK. BUT I
BET YOU THAT'S BEEN ECHOED
BEFORE BECAUSE I READ ONE OF
THESE COMMUNITIES OR YOU HAD
HOSPITALITY WORKERS WOULD YOU
HAD THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRIES
WE HAD LARGE SECTORS IN LARGE
POPULATIONS WHO COULDN'T GO TO
WORK IF YOU ASK ANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE. THEY WOULD HAVE WANTED
TO GO TO WORK BECAUSE I RENT TO
PAY. LITTLE KIDS TO FEED AND IT
WAS INCREDIBLY IN PARK THEY
WERE ONE PAYCHECK AWAY BEFORE.
FROM NOT BEING ABLE TO PAY THE
RENT. WELL THAT NOW IT'S ABOUT
FOUR FIVE PAYCHECKS BEHIND
WHERE THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO PAY
THE RENT LET ME VERY CLEAR. TO
THOSE THAT MAKES NO SENSE TO
PUNISH. SOMEBODY WHO FOR NO
REASON OUTSIDE OF A PANDEMIC
COULD NOT COME BACK TO WORK.
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR IF YOUR
BOTTOM LINE INDUSTRY. YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO TAKE AN EMPLOYEE
BACK WAS MAKING TWENTY BUCKS
OVER MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYEE. ALL
THIS BILL BASICALLY SIMPLY
SAYS. THE WAY I UNDERSTOOD THE
SENATE IS GIVE THAT EMPLOY THE
ABILITY TO COME BACK TO WORK
WITH THE WAR. IF THE EMPLOYEE
WITH BUDGET. THAT'S A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION LET'S HAVE IT BUT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE HERE THAT'S
NOT WITH HIS BILLS TRYING TO DO.
AND THERE IS THE AUTHOR CAN
CLEAR UP I BELIEVE IT'S THREE
DAYS NOW. THAT'S A VERY MODEST
SCHEDULING. ISSUE THAT I DON'T
THINK IT'S GONNA BREAK ANY
SMALL. I WITHOUT IRES CAN HIRE
TONIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER SANTA
TRIED AGAIN SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MISTER KALRA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANKS THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER THANK YOU TO
ALL MY COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE- ON
THIS MATTER. ARE YOU KNOW. IN
MY- IN MY DISTRICT I'VE SEEN
FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT OF CODE
NINETEEN IN THE BAY AREA. THREE
OF THE MOST HEAVILY IMPACTED
ZIP CODES ARE IN MY DISTRICT IN
THE SAN JOSE. WHY ARE THEY IN
THE DISTRICT. BECAUSE THOSE ARE
THE WORKING CLASS PEOPLE OF
SILICON VALLEY. THE LATINO
VIETNAMESE THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE WORKING HARD EVERYDAY
WASHING DISHES. CLEANING
BATHROOMS. BEING FORCED TO GO
TO WORK BECAUSE THEY'RE CALLED
ESSENTIAL YEAH THEY'RE BEING
TREATED AS IF THEIR SACRIFICIAL.
NOW I'M DOING MY BEST TO TRY TO
FIND SOME COMMON GROUND AND YES
I MEAN I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE AN
EMERGENCY CLAUSE ON THIS. I
WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
BELIEVE THAT TWO THIRDS THE
FOLKS BEFORE WOULD VOTE FOR IT
BUT URGENCY CLAUSE BUT- I'M
DOING I'M WORK WITH WHAT I HAVE
HERE. AND THE REALITY IS THAT.
POVICH WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
IT'S GOING TO BE WITH US BUT
THIS IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HELP US. FRAME THE EXPECTATION
FOR ANY PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES WOULD WANT TO GO
THROUGH THIS. AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND EVERY EMPLOYER. EVERY
COUNTY. EVERY WORKER. WILL KNOW
PRECISELY WHAT IT IS THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO WHEN THEY'RE BEING
TOLD TO GO HOME WHEN THEY SHOW
UP TO THE GROCERY STORE WHERE
THEY WORK AT. AND THE BOSS SAYS
ACCORDING TO THE COUNTY I HAVE
TO SEND YOU HME FOR TWO WEEKS.
ARE WE GONNA PUT ALL THE WORKER.
TO HAVE TO SACRIFICE TO MAKE IT
TO THOSE TWO WEEKS WERE
COMMUTERS OUT A LITTLE BIT OF
RELIEF TO HELP GET THEM THROUGH
THIS CRISIS. AS I STATED WE
WILL BE MAKING A MANAGED TO
REDUCE THE DAYS OF SEVEN TO
THREE DAYS WE WILL EXAMPLES
THIS IS THERE A CLOSE DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND
I'M COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
TALK WITH OPPOSITION ON THE
RIGHT A RECALL INVITED
RETENTION. THIS OF THE PEOPLE
WORKING ON THIS BILL ALL
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY BE MADE
TONS OF AMENDMENTS AND ASSEMBLY
APPROACH I'M GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON IT THAT'S HOW I
OPERATE. UNDER ASKING YOU TO
THINK OF THESE WERE. THERE IN
EVERYONE OF OUR DISTRICTS. IF
THEY'RE NOT ALREADY UNEMPLOYED
THEY'RE BEING FORCED TO GO TO
WORK IF THEY CAN'T JUST NOT
SHOW UP OR THEY'LL GET FIRED I
WOULD THEN THEY'RE TOLD THEY
HAVE TO GO HOME. LET'S THINK
ABOUT THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES I
THINK ABOUT THE LITTLE THAT WE
CAN DO TO HELP THEM IN THESE
VERY NARROW CIRCUMSTANCES. AND
I THINK IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT. WE CAN FIND THAT BALANCE
AND I'M I'M- THIS BILL FINDS
THAT BALANCE. AND I'M
COMMITTED. TO BRING BACK A BILL
ON CONCURRENT THAT YOU'LL-
YOU'LL BE HAPPY WITH. A YOU'LL
BE CONFIDENT. THAT WE DID
EVERYTHING WE COULD. TO STRIKE
THAT BALANCE WHILE. CONTINUING
TO HOLD ON TO THOSE CORE
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS. SO UP
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE AND LET'S THINK ABOUT
THESE WORKERS. AS THEY'RE OUT
THERE. SACRIFICING FOR US.
THANK YOU. THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
OWN MEMBERS VOTED. BOTH ALL
MEMBERS TO THEIR TO VOTE. ON
VOTED TO VOTE. OF MEMBERS THAT
YOU DESERVE A.
WHERE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE
AYES FORTY THREE KNOWS FIFTEEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBER WILL
MOVE BACK TO FILE ORDER RARE
PASSING IN RETAINING ON FILE
ITEMS TWO THROUGH NINE PASS
TEMPORARILY IN FILE ITEM TEN
MOVING A FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY NINETY THREE BY SOME THE
RIVER HOLDER ACCOLADE HEALING
ARTS. MR HOLDING YOU ARE A-
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER OF I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY THREE. THE BILL ABOUT
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND SAFETY
AND HEALTH CARE. AUTOMATIC
PHARMACY SYSTEMS CAN BE HELP
FOR PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS WHO TAKE DAILY
MEDICATIONS BY REDUCING LAG
TIME BETWEEN REFILLS. HOWEVER
SOME LARGE PHARMACIES HAVE
TAKEN THIS PROCESS A STEP TOO
FAR BY REQUESTING REFILLS
BEYOND WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY
PRESCRIBED. THE PRACTICE ALSO
INCLUDES BOMBARDING DOCTORS
WITH FACTS. A RESPONSE. FAR
BEYOND WHAT WAS PREVIOUSLY DONE
OVER. GAINES REFILL OVER. ARE
WE THE BOMBARDMENT OF REQUESTS
CAN EASILY LEAD TO MISTAKES
WHEN APPROVING THE DISPENSING
MEDICATION TO PATIENTS AB
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY THREE WOULD
ENSURE PATIENTS OPT END TO AN
AUTO REFILL PROGRAM IF THEY
WANT TO USE IT AND DOCTORS HAVE
MORE CONTROL TO ENSURE THE
NUMBER OF REFILLS A PATIENT
RECEIVES AS RECOMMENDED BY THE
DOCTOR. NOT THE PHARMACY. AN
EXAMPLE INCLUDES A PHARMACY
ASKING. TO REFILL A HIGH DOSE
OF VITAMIN D. SUPPLEMENTS
STATING THAT THE PATIENT
REQUEST OF THE REFILL. THE
DOCTOR WAS SURPRISED CALL THE
PATIENT TO CONFIRM THE PATIENTS
CITY ABSOLUTELY HAD NOT ASKED
FOR A REFILL. THIS MEDICATION
CAN LEAD TO TALK CITY AND
KIDNEY STONES. THE PHARMACY HAD
LIED AND USE THE AUTO REFILL
EXCUSE TO FAX AND CALL. THEIR
BEEN REFILL REQUESTS ON
DECEASED PATIENTS. A PATIENT
WHO CHANGE THEIR PHARMACY BUT
THE DOCTOR KEPT GETTING THE
FAXES AFTER THE FAXES
REQUESTING. A REFILL FROM THE
OLD PHARMACY. FIFTEEN REFILLS
ON A THREE MONTH SUPPLY OF
MEDICATION ALMOST FOUR YEARS
WORTH OF MEDICATION. IMAGINE
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THOSE
PATIENTS WHEN THOSE REQUESTS
ART LOOKED AT CLOSELY THINGS
FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS IN
MEMBER. AND A MEMBER OF THE
DOCTOR STAFF APPROVE IT.
MEDICAL WASTE AT BEST IMPATIENT
DANGER AT WORST. THE MEMBERS
CLARIFY THE WORD AUTOMATICALLY
TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THIRTY
DAY RESTRICTION DOES NOT APPLY
TO PEOPLE WHO OPT IN TO AUTO
REFILL PROGRAM. THE STRIKE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT EACH
PRESCRIPTION NEEDS A SEPARATE
WRITTEN AUTHORIZATION SO
PATIENTS CAN CONTINUE TO USE
THE AUTOMATIC REFILL PROGRAM AS
THEY ARE NOW. AND THEY DELAY
OPERATIVE DATE UNTIL TWENTY
pHAVE ENOUGH TIME TO IMPLEMENT
THE LAW OUTSIDE OF THE PANDEMIC.
I AM WILLING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH MEMBERS AND THE
OPPOSITION AND LET ME JUST SAY
I APPRECIATE ALL OF THE MEMBERS
TO RAISE THEIR CONCERNS AROUND
THIS BILL THE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS WERE ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS. BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE IN THE SENATE TO WORK.
OUR WITH THE OPPOSITION ON ANY
LINGERING CONCERNS. INCLUDING
INTENT LANGUAGE THAT CLARIFIES
THIS BILL DOES NOT HINDER
PATIENTS FROM USING AUTO REFILL
PROGRAMS REQUIRE PATIENTS TO
GIVE AUTHORIZATION MORE THAN
ONCE OR DEAD DICTATE HOW
AUTHORIZATION HAPPENS. I
BELIEVE THIS BILL BOTH
PRESERVES PATIENT SAFETY AND
ALLOWSTHE CONVENIENCE OF
AUTOMATIC REFILLS. THIS PUTS
THE POWER IN THE DOCTOR'S HANDS
AND DOES NOT INTERFERE WITH THE
WAY PATIENTS AND PHARMACISTS IN
IRAQ TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
HOLDEN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS. OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
THE WHERE. WHERE HELP CLOSE THE
ROW AND TALENTED I FORTY FIVE
KNOWS WELL THE MEASURE. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TWELVE AB. THIRTY
THREE THIRTY SIX. EIGHT SOME
PEOPLE THIRTY THIRTY SIX BY.
CARILLO OF FOOD. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MATTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS LET ME TAKE A
MOMENT A PRIVILEGE TO SAY THAT
TODAY'S A GOOD DAY TO BE A
DREAMER. I AM PROUD TO PRESENT.
IF I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX A
CRITICAL BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE
BASIC CONSUMER CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AGAINST FOOD
CONTAMINATION FROM READY TO EAT
DELIVERY SERVICES BY
ESTABLISHING PRINCIPLE
SAFEGUARDS THE IMPORTANCE OF AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX WHICH
MY OFFICE BEGAN TO WORK BEFORE
OR COLD AT NIGHT IN IS
HEIGHTENED EVEN MORE IN LIGHT
OF THE PEN MAKE AND THE NEW. WE
ARE ALL LIVING IN WEARING A
FACEMASK SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
SHELTERING IN PLACE AS WE HAVE
ALL SEEN AT HOME DELIVERY
SERVICES HAVE SKYROCKETED AS
RESTAURANTS WERE FORCED TO SHUT
DOWN MANY OF THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WE ALL SUPPORT
AND THE PUBLIC WAS ORDERED TO
SHELTER IN PLACE HOWEVER. TO
FOOD. ABLE HAVE AN MANY REST
REMAIN FOR TO THE STUFF TIME AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX WILL
ENHANCE FOOD SAFETY ACROSS THE
STATE WHICH IS PARTICULARLY
CRITICAL AT THIS TIME NEVER TO
ADDRESS ISSUES RAISED IN POLICY
COMMITTEE THIS WEEK LEON MY-
OFFICE TO GO. THE FOOD ALLEN.
X. A GROCERY STORES FROM THIRD
PARTY DELIVERY REQUIREMENTS AN
EXAMPLE- TRANSPORTED AS PART OF
A TERRIBLE FEEDING PROGRAM FROM
SPECIFIED REQUIREMENTS LET ME
BE CLEAR THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL IS NOT TO MAKE IT HARDER
FOR PEOPLE TO WORK IN FACT THE
OPPOSITE. AND LET ME TAKE A
MOMENT AS WELL TO THINK THE
READY TO EAT FOOD DELIVERY
DRIVERS AS WELL AS THE
RESTAURANT WORKERS WE HAVE BEEN
WITH CHAU WORKERS AMID THIS
GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND WHO HAVE
RISKED THEIR LIVES EVERY DAY I
MADE AN EFFORT. EARNED KIND OF
INCOME PER FURTHER FAMILIES PAY
THE RENT AND HAVE ALLOWED
SEVERAL OTHERS THE PRIVILEGE
SHELTERING IN PLACE THESE WERE
FIRST ARE SO. FOR FISH. MEMBERS
THE PURPOSE THE LOWEST FOR THE
PUBLIC. ENSURING THAT READY TO
EAT FOOD IS NOT TAMPERED WITH
WITH A NO BREAK FEEL OR OTHER
METHODS OF CLOSURE IT PROTECTS
THE INTEGRITY OF THE FOOD
PROVIDED BY RESTAURANTS WHERE
THE FOOD IS PREPARED IN SHORT
THE CONSUMERS YOU FOR FAMILIES.
ARE NOT EXPOSED TO ANYONE
OUTSIDE OF THE RESTAURANT
TAMPERING WITH YOUR FOOD THIS
BILL IS COMMON SENSE IT ALIGNS
WITH MODERN SOCIETY AND OUR USE
OF TECHNOLOGY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
COME. BEGIN THE NECESSARY
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TO THEN
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
PRIVATE VEHICLES FOR THIS TYPE
OF DELIVERY CERTIFIED BACKLIT
ACOSTA I'VE- YEAH SEEING IN
HERE. FOR THEIR DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THE- ALL
MEMBERS THE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELEVOTE ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS
FIFTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES. NO
BUT THEN I.
MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY
ONE I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE YOU TO REFER TO THE
FOLLOWING BUDGET RELATED BILLS
TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE SB
EIGHT OH NINE THROUGH A FORTY
EIGHT INCLUSIVE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SAID TO BE THE ORDER.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE WILL READ
SOME MIDDLE TWENTY SIX FIFTY
FIVE BY SOME THE RIVER GIPSON
ACCOLADE AND CRIMES. MR GIVING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL I'M TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE WHICH SEEKS TO MAKE.
IT A MISDEMEANOR FOR A FIRST
RESPONDER TO CAPTURE AND NOT
AUTHORIZED IMAGE OF A DECEASED
PERSON OR PERSONS AT THE CITY
OF AN ACCIDENT A CRIME. FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE TRUSTED TO
SECURE AND PRESERVE SCENES OF
GREAT DISASTER AND DEATH AFTER
THE JANUARY TWENTY SIX
HELICOPTER CRASH. THAT CLAIMED
THE LIFE OF KOBE BRYANT AND HIS
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER AND
SEVEN OTHERS FIRST RESPONDERS
SHARED. IMAGES OF THE CRIME
SCENE. WITH OWN PERSONAL USE
THIS ACT WAS ABUSIVE AND ABUSE
OF POWER AND EXTREMELY
INSENSITIVE AND GRIEVING TO THE
FAMILY AND LOVED ONES OF THE
DISEASE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX FIFTY FIVE WILL SEE. TO
INSURE THAT DIGNITY OF THE
DISEASE AS WELL AS THE PRIVACY
OF THE LOWER ONES ARE PROTECTED
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE
VOTE. ON IS THE BILL TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
GIPSON SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR-
YEAH. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY KNOWS HERE THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
MIDDLE TWENTY FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER
ACCOLADES FOR MERCY SERVICES.
AS COM ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR THE CRISIS ACT WILL
ESTABLISH A PILOT PROGRAM TO
SCALE UP COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AS FIRST
RESPONDERS. INTERACTIONS WITH
POLICE CAN BE SCARY FOR MANY
PEOPLE. WELL IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SITUATIONS WITH
IMMIGRANT STATUS CONCERNS WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS WITH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY PEOPLE WHO ARE BLACK
AND OTHER FOLKS HISTORICALLY
TRAUMATIZED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
ALL WANT RESOLUTIONS AND
SOLUTIONS TO THE PROBLEMS.
CAUSING THEM DISTRESS. BUT THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE SHAMED OR
JUDGED FOR THEIR PERSON OR
CIRCUMSTANCE THEY DON'T WANT TO
REST SOMETIMES THEY DON'T WANT
CHARGES THEY DON'T WANT A
FATALITY. THEY WANTED DE
ESCALATED RESOLUTION AND THEY
WANT FAMILY AND COMMUNITY PIECE
THEY WANT PUBLIC SAFETY BUT NOT
AT THE COST OF A LIFE. FOR MOST
OF US NINE ONE ONE IS THE ONLY
OPTION FOR ANY CRISIS AND YET
FOR MANY WE DON'T WANT TO
ENGAGE WITH WHOEVER IS ON THE
OTHER LINE BECAUSE THE RESPONSE
IS OFTENTIMES NOT SCALABLE. SO
MANY COMMUNITIES AND UP LESS
SAFE AS A RESULT. AB TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR IS ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HEALTH BILL IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT. LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS OVER TROUT I'M TRAUMATIZED
UNDER TRAINED IN CERTAIN
INSTANCES AND SOMETIMES ON
SYMPATHETIC TO CERTAIN CALLS.
CURRENTLY WE ASK OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS TO SHIFT THE
ADRENALINE THE TACTIC AND THE
FORCE THAT THEY USE TO
APPREHEND AN ARMED ROBBER FOR
EXAMPLE TO THE SCHIZOPHRENIC
YOUNG MALE. THAT IS UNREALISTIC
AND IT'S ON Y. AND CAN BE FATAL
WHEN THOSE TWO PEOPLE APPEAR TO
BE THE SAME PERSON IN THE EYES
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT. THàNH HALL
MOTHER OF MILES HALL A TWENTY
THREE YEAR OLD WALNUT CREEK
RESIDENT. WHO WAS KILLED A YEAR
AGO DURING A SCHIZO AFFECTIVE
DISORDER INDUCED CRISIS SAYS
THAT IF THIS BILL HAD EXISTED A
YEAR AGO HER SON WOULD BE ALIVE.
OF COURSE THIS IS ALSO A
COMMUNITY HEALTH BILL IN CITIES
ACROSS THE STATE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE RESPONDING
SUCCESSFULLY TO EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS INVOLVING ON HOUSE
PEOPLE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS FOLKS
EXPOSED TO VIOLENCE FOLKS
EXPERIENCING SUBSTANCE OF THIS
AND PEOPLE IMPACTED BY NATURAL
OR CLIMATE DISASTERS. YET
DESPITE THE POSITIVE IMPACT
THAT IN COST SAVINGS OF THESE
COMMUNITY ORIENTED RESPONSES TO
EMERGENCIES OUR STATE HAS DONE
LITTLE TO SUPPORT AND SCALE UP
THESE EFFORTS. INSTEAD WE'RE
ASKING LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
CONTINUE TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES BETTER SUITED TO
PEER SUPPORT EXPERTS MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS OR CRISIS
COUNSELORS TRAINED TO DE
ESCALATE AND RESOLVE CRISES. AB
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR WOULD
MARSHALL IN AN ARRAY OF
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS TO QUIP
TO STEP IN AS FIRST RESPONDERS
THESE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
CREDIBILITY WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND VALUE THE LIFE
AND CIRCUMSTANCE. OF PEOPLE WHO
REQUIRE HELP. X. ENDING ROLLING
CAN BE PARTNERS DE NOT MEAN A
LIMóN LINE FOR. IT MEANS YOU
ARE EMPOWERING GROUPS WHO HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT THEY CAN
PROTECT THEIR COMMUNITIES WHILE
OFFERING THE POLICE TO FOCUS ON
ISSUES MORE SUITED FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRAINING. AB TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE WITH ZERO
NO VOTES THE BILL IS ALSO
SUPPORTED BY MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS FROM A VARIETY OF
SECTORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I WOULD LIKE
TO OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS COM LONGER I'M
SORRY BUT THIS IS A BILLS WE
WILL NOT BE HOLDING THE ROLE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS- BUT SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO THE- HOME
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH
I'LL FILE ITEM FIFTEEN WILL
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
SIXTEEN THROUGH NINETEEN.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
THE DEATH WILL BE OPEN HELD
OPEN THE PROCESS BUDGET RELATED
AMENDMENTS AND TO RECEIVE
SENATE MESSAGES. CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE
FIFTY ONE I MOVE THAT WE
ADJOURN FOR SUMMER RECESS TO
RECONVENE ON MONDAY JULY
THIRTEENTH OR UPON CALL THE
SPEAKER AND CONSENT FOR THE
SENATE TO DO TO DO THE SAME
WHEN THEY ADJOURNED. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. IN THE ABSENCE REJECTION
THE PART OF.
IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALLS
LIFTED WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS ARE TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR WE
ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR WE
ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY THANK YOU.
MR FUNG YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
A MEMORY. I THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO REMEMBER AND HONOR A
WONDERFUL COMMUNITY LEADER AMY
BECAUSE THE COVERT KNOWN FOR
POSITIVITY IN TIGHTNESS SHE WAS
TRULY A GUIDING LIGHT TO SO
MANY IN THE RICH GUYS COMMITTEE.
SHE WAS ELECTED TO THE SIERRA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD
OF TRUSTEES IN TWO THOUSAND.
SHE ALSO SERVED FAITHFULLY FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE AS A BOARD
DELEGATE TO THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE A FEDERALLY IMPACTED
SCHOOLS SHE TRAVELED FREQUENT A
WASHINGTON DC. TO RAISE
AWARENESS AND ADVOCATE FOR THE
NEEDS OF OUR REMOTE FINANCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED SCHOOLS. SHE WAS
A TREMENDOUS ADVOCATE FOR
SPECIAL NEEDS CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THERE WAS
NOTHING SHE WOULDN'T DO TO HELP
STUDENTS SO THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED.
SHE WOULD TREAT EVERYONE LIKE
FAMILY AMY MADE EVERYONE FEEL
WELCOME AS A GREETER AND
RECEPTIONIST AT THE RIDGECREST
REGIONAL HOSPITAL. AMY WAS
ALWAYS CHECKING IN OUR FRIENDS
OF FAMILY SENDING THEM I NEED A
BIBLE VERSE ARE OFFERING A
PRAYER. I WAS LUCKY LUCKY TO
HAVE HER AS A FRIEND. WORDS
CANNOT DESCRIBE HOW MUCH WILL
MISTER DEVOTION AND COMMITMENT
TO OUR COMMUNITY I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF A MAKE
A STEEL COVER COVERT. THANK YOU
MISTER FUNK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YOUR SECOND INTERMEMBRANE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I RISE
TO ALSO REMEMBER BOB HAMPTON A
MENTOR FRIEND AND COMMITTEE
LEADER AND WESTERN COUNTY. BOB
LOVE THE COMMUNITY OF TAFT HE
WAS A STAR ATHLETE AT TAFT HIGH
SCHOOL PLAYING FOOTBALL
BASKETBALL AND BASEBALL BEFORE
GOING ON TO PLAY BASKETBALL AT
USC. HE RETURNED TO KERN COUNTY
LATER TO TEACH AND COACH AND
AFTER TWELVE YEARS COACHING
BASKETBALL AT SOUTHWESTERN AND
WEST SO JUNIOR COLLEGES HE
WOULD LEAVE EDUCATION TO GO
INTO PRIVATE BUSINESS. FOR
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS HE OWNED AND
OPERATED WEST SIDE WASTE
MANAGEMENT BUT HE WOULD STAY
ACTIVE IN THE COMMUNITY SERVING
THIRTEEN YEARS AND THE KERN
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AS WELL AS AN ON
NUMEROUS BOARDS IN
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING TAFT
WAS DONE IN AND HE'S WAS A
ABBOTT OF THE CURRENT. USC CLUB.
I WAS INCREDIBLE FRIEND AND
ANSWERED ALL WHO KNEW HIM. GET
A LARGER THAN LIFE PERSONALITY
AND HAS SUCH A GENEROUS HEART.
HE WE MESSED BUT HAS LEFT A
LEGACY FOR ALL OF US TO ASPIRE
TO. I ASKED WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MY DEAR FRIEND BOB
AND- THANK YOU MISTER FONG. MR
MR GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY THE
FRONT OF THE CHAMBER. THANK
YOU. MAN SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
IT'S WITH MUCH SADNESS AND I
RISE TODAY WITH A HEAVY HEART.
TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF A GOOD
FRIEND WHO SAN MATEO LAZCANO.
TREMENDOUS SOCIAL JUSTICE IN
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS ADVOCATE. WHO
MY COMMUNITY LOST ON JUNE NINTH
OF THIS YEAR MUDDY WAS BORN IN
MEXICO CITY IN NINETEEN FIFTY.
AND UNFORTUNATELY LOST HIS
BATTLE TO CANCER- JUST A FEW
DAYS AGO. MONEY WAS GRADUATE
FROM POLYTECHNICAL UNIVERSITY
OF MEXICO. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT- WAS KNOWN FOR-
DURING HIS TIME AS A UNIVERSITY
STUDENT. WHAT'S HIS
PARTICIPATION AT THE THROUGHOUT
THE LOCAL MASSACRE THAT TOOK
PLACE ON OCTOBER SECOND
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. STUDENT
DEMONSTRATION IN MEXICO CITY
WHICH RESULTED IN THE TRAGIC
KILLINGS OF. THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS AT THE HANDS OF THE
MILITARY. IN MEXICO. AFTER
SURVIVING THAT. IT WILL BE SEEN
SUCH INJUSTICE. HE LOOKED TO
AMERICA FOR THE HOPE OF FREEDOM
AND OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR MY YOU
CAME TO THE UNITED STATES TO
WORK IN THE FIELDS AND PACKING
PLANTS. IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
OUT OF THIS HUMBLE HOME
PATELLA. MY DO BEGAN HELPING
HUNDREDS NAVIGATE THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF BECOMING LEGAL
RESIDENTS OF THE UNITED STATES.
OFTEN FOR VERY LITTLE MONEY IF
ANY. MY TO BELIEVE THAT A
PERSON VALUE WAS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO WHAT HE CAN OFFER TO
OTHERS. IS THAT PHILOSOPHY THAT
MOTIVATED HIS QUEST FOR JUSTICE
AND WAVERING SERVICE TO OUR
COMMUNITY. MARIO WILL BE BEST
KNOWN AS AN ADVOCATE FOR
IMMIGRANTS AND A FIGHTER FOR
JUST WORKING CONDITIONS. IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY. OUR STATE AND
FOR OUR NATION. HE BECAME A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE LATINO A GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION ADVOCATING FOR
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS. IF YOU ASKED
HIM IF HE WAS THE FOUNDER THE
LEADER HERE WE SAID THAT IT WAS
NOT HIM AND IT WAS A GROUP.
THAT WAS IN CHARGE OF MAKING
DECISIONS. ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMITTEE LATINO VERY HUMBLE.
INDIVIDUAL A TO SAY THE LEAST.
IS ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS THE ALIEN COALITION. FOR
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE COULD TELL
VALLEY IMMIGRANT DIGNITY
COALITION EAST WEST ALLIANCE.
ONE ORGANIZATION THAT HE WAS
MOST PROUD OF BEING A PART OF.
WHAT ALLOWED HIM TO BE CLOSER
TO GOD. AND TO WALK THE TALK ON
BEHALF OF HIS FELLOW. FRIENDS
COLLEAGUES WAS THE VALLEY
MISSIONARY PROGRAM OF THE
COACHELLA VALLEY. WERE THERE HE
WAS ABLE TO CELEBRATE. LIFE AND
OF COURSE DIGNITY OF ALL PEOPLE
THE PERSON WHO COINED THE
PHRASE IN OUR COMMUNITY NO
HUMAN IS ILLEGAL. IN RECENT
YEARS HIS EFFORTS INVOLVED
IMPROVING POLICE AND COMMUNITY
ENGAEMENT ADVOCATING FOR
SANCTUARY CITIES TO PROTECT OUR
FAMILIES FROM SEPARATION. AND
HOLDING DEMONSTRATIONS AGAINST
THE POLICIES. THAT PROMOTED
SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM THEIR
FAMILIES AT THE BORDER. MARIO
WILL BE REMEMBERED BY LEGACY AS
AN ACTIVIST AND LEADER.
INTERNALLY WE LOVE THAN OUR
COMMUNITY AS AN ORGANIZER ON
THE FRONTLINE OF CRITICAL HUMAN
RIGHTS IMMIGRANT AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES. HE WILL BE
GREATLY MISSED BUT AS LIFE
LEGACY AND FIGHT LIVES ON REST
IN POWER MY FRIEND AS I ASKED
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE CALPERS
STATE ASSEMBLY. TO JEN'S MEMORY.
MARIO BUT SO FAR MEDIA. AND
MONO SAID MINOR. SO MARINO
SALINAS LOOK WHEN YOU DON DATA
THIS TIME WAS WE'RE GONNA SEALS.
OR THAT MICHAEL LA ALCON OF
THEIR CRAFT. AND CAMINO CAVITY
ON ALEJO'S HE SAYS HE'LL SEE
I'LL- IN A SYSTEM BY USING IT
ON THIS NO SOLO UNDERSTOOD WHY
THEY COULD TELL UP IT'LL PULL
THIS STYLE YES IF I USE. SEC
ALATE MRS DUST WHICH ON THE
SYSTEM YET ON THE- DELIVERED ON
THE- NOW THIS IS THE ONLY LIKE
WHAT ISSUE BUT I'M NOT. GET TO
THE MORE COWBOY BUT APPROVED
THE CANISTER SYSTOLE ON THIS
DHAKA GIVE WITHIN TWO YEARS.
COMO PARTE DEL SWING AMITY
CONICAL DO WE END OF. ICE THAT
NANCY ON. GALA SEALED LINDA
PUTTING IT ON THIS MODEL OF
ALMOST ESTáN YEAH. THERE ARE
NO LONGER SOLD THAT YOU SEE IT
IN WE'LL SEE IN THE- WHO'S ALL
CLOSE YOUR HEELS. IN OCONEE
THAT BUT I'VE BEEN YEAH. IN
VOTING CONTRA THE REQUESTED
ASSOCIATED. IT'S GOT IMPOSSIBLE
MATEO FRONT OF ANIMALS. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
JUST THREE DAYS AGO. SANTA CRUZ
LOST ONE OF ITS BRIGHTEST STARS.
I ALSO TENDERED WAS WALKING
HOME WITH THEIR DAUGHTER MOLLY.
AND THEY WERE STRUCK BY A CAR.
MOLLY IS INJURED BUT HEALING.
AND ALISON UNFORTUNATELY LOST
HER LIFE. HOUSE AND HAS DEEP
DEEP CONNECTIONS INTO THE
COMMUNITY SHE FIRST CAME AS A
STUDENT UC SANTA CRUZ AND GOT
INVOLVED. IN POLITICS BECAUSE
SHE WAS ON A MISSION TO CARE
FOR OTHERS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE WHO HAD NO VOICE HOW TO
VOICE. TO DETERMINE A CHANGE
THE WORLD IN FACT SHE REALLY
DID. SHE WAS FORTY THREE. SHE
WAS SO SUCCESSFUL. AS AS AS A
STUDENT. THAT SHE WAS GIVEN THE
TASK OF. GOING OUT AND DOING
VOTER REGISTRATION IN FACT
ANYONE WHO NOW GETS THAT TASK
HAS TO LIVE UP TO THE STANDARD
SHE SAID. SHE'S ONE KNOWN FOR
SETTING STANDARDS AND KNOWN FOR.
WORKING REALLY AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS SHE THEN RAN
JOHNMYERS DISTRICT OFFICE WHEN
HE WAS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
SIX YEARS. AND HAS SINCE WORKED
FOR COUNTY SUPERVISOR. ALISON
WAS THE ONE THAT MADE SURE THAT
THE COMMUNITIES WERE STRONGER
BECAUSE OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
WERE IMPLEMENTED. SHE HAD
ABSOLUTELY NO PATIENCE FOR
PATRIARCHAL AND OPPRESSIVE
SYSTEMS BY IMMENSE PATIENTS FOR
THOSE WHO NEED A GOVERNMENT TO
WORK FOR THEM AND SHE MADE IT
HER RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE
GOVERNMENT WORK FOR THEM. NOW I
KNOW HER DAUGHTERS MOLLY LUCY.
ARE WATCHING THIS. AND TO YOU
WELL IN THIS WHO WE ARE SO
SORRY AT YOUR LAW AND THE ACHE
THAT YOU FEEL WE ALL FEEL. IN
THE COMMUNITY. TIME WILL HEAL
BUT WILL NEVER FILL THE VOID.
THAT THAT YOU'RE FEELING RIGHT
NOW. AN AND THE HER PARTNER OF
TWENTY ONE YEARS WHO IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE ONLY ONES
WHO COULD STAND UP TO THE
STRENGTH AND THE POWER OF
SOMEONE LIKE ALISON WHOM WE ALL
LOVED. BECAUSE OF THOSE
ATTRIBUTES OF HER.
UNWILLINGNESS TO BAND. AND MAKE
THE SYSTEMS FUNCTION THE WAY
THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO. AND
FEARED. A LITTLE BECAUSE OF THE
STANDARDS SHE SET ME WE'RE ALL.
MAYBE I'M JUST SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF A LITTLE AFRAID TO
DISAPPOINT ALISON. IN WHAT SHE
KNEW WAS RIGHT. SO WITH A VERY
HEAVY HEART AND SADNESS FOR
INCREDIBLE FAMILY I ASK THAT
THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF ALISON ANDERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER STRADDLED.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
TO THE DEATH TO BE PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL ALL REQUEST RETURN
IN THE MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAINED ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED. MR BONTA
MOVES IN MISTER OVER NOW TO
SECOND THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY JULY
THIRTEENTH. OR UPON CALL OF THE
SPEAKER. YOU DO IT AFTER.
AND
IT'S NOT ON THE LINE YEP RIGHT
ON VOTE CHANGE BOERNER HORVATH
AB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN FROM I TO
NOT VOTING. MODE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
SOME LEGAL THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN
I'D TO NOT LOADING.